good morning Hank it's Monday so
yesterday I was reading the newspaper
this is a newspaper Hank it's like the
Internet only it doesn't update it's not
interactive it's printed on very thinly
sliced trees and it's not free it's a
wonder these guys are having trouble
staying in business but I was reading
the newspaper because I'm an old person
and I saw a headline that said okay you
fix the budget then at first I was like
that's a really good idea we should turn
American fiscal policy over to a young
adult novelist who's currently wearing
his face on his torso
which reminds me had got long last
defamed Pizza shirt is back it is in
stock at dftba.com slash pizza which
means if you order it today it ships
tomorrow at least until we run out so
nerdfighters if you like me mustaches
pizza and your torso you should bring
those things together there's a link in
the doobly-doo right but so the New York
Times wanted me to solve the budget
crisis and they created a web-based tool
to help me do so and know the budget
tool does not have a liberal bias you
can go on there and click which taxes
you want to raise and what spending you
want to cut and find a way to balance
the budget so here's the astonishing
thing Hank if America did everything the
Democratic leadership is proposing in
the way of raising taxes we would still
have a huge budget deficit and if we did
everything the Republican leadership is
proposing in terms of spending cuts we
would still have a huge deficit that's
not the astonishing thing the
astonishing thing is that if we
implemented all the Democratic tax
increases and all the Republican
spending cuts we would still have a huge
deficit all right so here's a radical
oversimplification of the current
federal balance sheet as you can see the
vast majority of the federal budget goes
to Social Security Medicare Medicaid and
the Department of Defense that other by
the way includes other mandatory
spending programs the biggest chunk of
which is unemployment insurance so maybe
you cut all of Social Security or
Medicare or Medicaid or just eliminate
our army okay so putting aside the fact
that none of that will ever happen
because we're not going to eliminate our
army and we're not going to eliminate
Social Security or Medicare because old
people vote and old people like that
stuff if we for instance eliminated
Medicare we wouldn't actually decrease
the federal budget by the amounts shown
there because old people would still get
sick and need care and some of them
wouldn't be able to pay for and we would
end up eating the cost somehow so those
of you who would say there's an easy
solution
I disagree so Hank I can make an
argument as I have in the past that
pennies are stupid and they cost us
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
and we should get rid of them
because they're idiotic and that's true
but getting rid of the penny wouldn't
actually solve the deficit crisis that
we have coming so the great thing about
this New York Times app which I
encourage you all to check out is that
it makes it clear that it won't be easy
and I think what most people will find
and certainly what I found is that there
are things that I would like not to cut
that still need to be cut and taxes that
I would like not to be raised that still
need to be raised which is really the
case with any budget like when I draw up
my budget I always find that there are
things that I would like to do that I
can't do like for instance purchase this
dress instead I have to Photoshop myself
into it and there are things that
generate revenue that I have to do even
though I don't necessarily want to do
them all right nerdfighters so
non-rhetorical question of the day using
this app in the doobly-doo were you able
to balance the federal budget and how
fortunately Hank tomorrow I'm leaving
for a week in Europe where they have all
this stuff figured out what's then
really actually turns out that the
deficit projections for most developed
economies look a lot like this
so yeah Hank I got to go pack for Europe
I'm doing some events in Amsterdam and
Vienna there's information about that in
the doobly-doo and also up but before I
go I do have one really good piece of
news if I've learned anything from my
introduction to federal budget deficits
it's that we need more mathematicians in
places of power and Brotherhood 2.0
resident mathematician and future state
representative Daniel Biss is now a
state representative elect yes
nerdfighters were going to Congress
state Congress but still Hank I'll see
you on Wednesday
ok PostScript I just had to go buy
diapers and wipes at the grocery store
and the guy checking out the diapers was
looking at my shirt and then he looked
at me and he was like is that you and I
was like yes yes it is